[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la France va se prononcer sur le mode
d'élection du président de la République
les bureaux des mairies ont été pris
d'assaut le nombre de ceux qui ont tenu
à régulariser leur situation de citoyens
à traduit l'importance de la prochaine
consultation pendant ce temps les
rotatifs débités les planches de oui et
de nom oui ou non le président de la
République sera-t-il élu par tous les
citoyens si la réponse est positive elle
transformera la vie politique de l'État
pour comprendre la pensée du général de
Gaulle il convient d'interroger
l'histoire il y a 4 ans c'est à
l'unanimité ou presque que le général de
Gaulle a été appelé par le peuple
français et chacun se rappelle les
circonstances récentes dans lesquelles
la République et les libertés
démocratiques ont été en danger le chef
de l'État a pu alors agir grâce à cette
base populaire qui devait ensuite
largement approuver son action
or en 1914 à la veille de la Grande
Guerre Raymond Poincaré président de la
République avouait à un familier je suis
président de la République et je ne peux
rien faire
réélu en 1939 le président Albert Lebrun
ne pouvait trouver dans sa fonction
l'autorité indispensable devant la
conjoncture internationale
dans le Floride la victoire en 1918 Paul
Deschanel fut préféré par le Congrès de
Versailles à Clémenceau dont le grand
caractère effrayait
et lorsque Milan voulu faire prendre au
président de la République une part plus
active dans la politique du pays il fut
obligé d'y renoncer pour désigner le
successeur de Vincent Auriol il ne
fallut pas moins de 14 scrutins élus
dans de telles conditions à la suite de
multiples transactions de quelle
autorité pouvait se prévaloir un
président de la République
[Musique]
c'est cette autorité que le général de
Gaulle veut donner à son successeur et
pour cela il propose aux Français qui
auront un décider de lui apporter le
soutien massif et officiel du suffrage
universel ce soutien qu'il connaît lui
sous la forme de l’acclamation et du
consentement général
[Musique]
Bruxelles a vécu un dimanche agitée le
Comité d'action flamand pour Bruxelles
et la frontière linguistique avait
organisé une deuxième marche sur la
capitale
agitant l'emblème des Flandres les
marcheurs que les autorités ont estimé à
50 000 ont entrepris de traverser la
ville cette intrusion en masse n'a la
pas sans provoquer les réactions des
contre manifestants francophones et
c'est ainsi qu'on allait très vite en
venir aux mains
[Applaudissements]
un certain point névralgique la
gendarmerie une forte affaire pour
séparer les antagonistes il y a eu des
blessés on en a relevé une vingtaine
c'est le bilan de la journée un bilan
trop lourd
il fallut dit-on la nouvelle de la
victoire de l'équipe belge de football
sur la Hollande pour calmer les esprits
Bruxelles en tout cas souhaiterait
passer des dimanches plus calmes
[Musique]
avoue-le entre la France et Monaco rien
ne va plus mais on n'entend pas encore
tonner les canons du château autour de
son port et de son rocher Monaco a
beaucoup grandi en disant non en surface
on y dispose que de 150 hectares mais en
hauteur
[Musique]
et il semble bien que les building aient
poussé en fonction du nombre des
sociétés qui se sont installées dans ce
pays sans impôts autant dire de rêves
or ou réalise-t-elle tout naturellement
le gros de leur chiffre d'affaires en
France et en échappant au fils la
frontière est tellement symbolique le
fruitier est à Monaco le boulanger d'en
face dans les Alpes-Maritimes or en
pleine nuit un premier barrage de
douaniers a été installé première mesure
de pression Monaco sera-t-il territoire
étranger où les négociations
franco-monnaques suspendus
reprendront-elles pour aboutir à un
accord fiscal
[Musique]
les mouvements de l'escadre de
Méditerranée faisait partie de la
dernière phase des grandes manœuvres
navales françaises dernière phase à
laquelle était venue assister le général
de Gaulle sur le porte-avion Clemenceau
le chef de l'État devait suivre le
déroulement d'une série d'exercices qui
commencèrent par le catapultage d'Alizée
d'Aquilon et des tas
attaque du porte-avion riposte
ainsi ça se fait pour le Clemenceau et
une vingtaine de bâtiments de la Marine
nationale l'exercice Linois dont le
thème était la protection d'un convoi en
Méditerranée occidentale
[Musique]
cependant l'Auvergne ne tardait pas à se
voir à saillie par des vagues
successives de parachutistes du parti
rouge
le général de Gaulle était venu
également assister aux dernières
péripéties de l'opération Dassas seconde
phase des grandes manœuvres de l'armée
de terre
[Musique]
les rouges ayant fini par installer une
tête de pont ou camp de la courtine au
parti bleu de légender avec l'aide des
gendarmes et des réservistes cartel
était le but des manœuvres mettre en
œuvre la défense intérieure du
territoire on fit à cette occasion
connaissance avec le nouvel engin léger
du combat même arrosé des sens enflammés
il poursuit ses évolutions parfaitement
à l'aise
le chou se porte cette saison sur la
tête d'une manière disons-le très
parisienne pour tout avouer c'est le nom
de la nouvelle ligne de coiffure à la
mode cheveux courts en plan superposé
symbrisant les uns dans les autres à la
façon des feuilles de chou une certaine
hauteur de casque comme on dit dans le
métier et voilà vous savez tout avec une
frange bande auréolant le front c'est le
style Grandjean interprété par Serge
sterre
ambulance rapidement avec un diadème
pour les grands soirs signés
Jean-Clément
[Musique]
hiératique avec la nostalgie de l'Egypte
c'est la coiffure Néfertiti de Fernand
Aubry
plan contrarié rajeunissement de la
ligne fin de siècle une interprétation
de gombo Saintonge
architecture compliquée avec un effet de
chignon fait de mèche savante Luc
traîneau a réussi une création
étonnamment jeune
enveloppante elle est la marque
d'Antoine Salvador mais attention il y a
chou et chou
[Musique]
pour 500 millions de catholiques c'est
l'événement du siècle qui a commencé à
Rome avec la procession vers la
basilique Saint-Pierre de 2400 paires de
l'église autrement dit de la
quasi-totalité des archevêques des
évêques des patriarches des supérieurs
d'ordre venus des quatre coins du monde
cette procession exceptionnelle près
ludette à l'ouverture par le pape Jean
XXII du concile ecuménique une foule
immense de fidèles 300 000 la place
Saint-Pierre n'en contient pas plus
était là pour saluer le souverain
pontife
un peu plus tard la grande nef de
Saint-Pierre offrait le spectacle du
pape et des pères rassemblés pour
débattre des questions qui intéressent
tout le monde catholique
spectacle leur arissime puisque c'est la
21e fois seulement dans l'histoire de
l'Église que le concile est réuni le
dernier le fut en 1869 l'avant-dernier
au 16e siècle
la journée devait s'achever par une
procession du Colisée à Saint-Pierre 10
000 flammes illuminèrent la place où
s'était retrouvé une foule aussi dense
au matin
de sa fenêtre Jean XXII donna sa
bénédiction fidèle ce fut là la première
grande journée du concile
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]